let's say i'm person a here in my ship
traveling through the universe at a
constant velocity so that is person a
right over there let me write it a
little bit bigger
person a
and let's say that i have a friend
person b and they are in another ship
and in my frame of reference so this is
person b in my frame of reference
they are traveling so their velocity
vector looks like this
they are traveling
at eight tenths of the speed of light
zero
point eight
c and so once again this is all given in
a's frame of reference in my frame of
reference
now the question i have for you is
surely there must be some third party
let's call them let's call them c
for
convenience
surely there must be some third party or
some third-party frame of reference and
we could imagine it might be someone in
some ship
where their velocity in my frame of
reference is in between being stationary
and traveling 0.8 times the velocity of
light and even more from their frame of
reference a and b should be leaving or
going outward from them at the same
velocity so what am i talking about so
this is
we're going to in this column i'll write
the frame of reference so this first row
is a's frame of reference that we just
described and c is going to be going
with some velocity v
away
away from a
so some velocity v we haven't figured it
out yet
now let's think about c's frame of
reference so frame of reference c
so c in c's frame of reference is just
going to be stationary
and we want to figure out a v so that a
and b are are moving away from c at the
same velocity so in this frame of
reference
a
will look like
will look like it's moving to the left
with a with a velocity of negative e or
its magnitude is the same but just in
the other direction and b will also be
moving away with velocity v
so
b right over here is going to be moving
away with velocity v
so this is a really interesting question
can we figure out what v is going to be
if we were dealing with the galilean
world you might say well v is just going
to be halfway in between these two
things if we were just on the highway in
a galilean or newtonian world and b is
going 80 miles per hour
and a is stationary well then if c goes
halfway if c is going 40 miles per hour
then from c's point of view it looks
like a is going backwards at 40 miles
per hour and it would look like b is
going forward at 40 miles per hour but
we know by now that we don't deal we
aren't living in a newtonian or galilean
universe where we're living in one
defined by special relativity so i
encourage you to pause the video and
figure out what this this in-between
frame of reference what its velocity
needs to be relative to a and i'll give
you a hint it's going to
involve the einstein velocity addition
formula
so let's work through this together so
i'm just going to write down the
einstein velocity addition formula so it
tells us
that
the change in x
all right check your change in x prime
with respect to t prime is equal to
u
minus v
over
1 minus u v
over c squared now let's think about how
we might apply it and the trick here is
to really think about it from from c's
frame of reference
is to think about it from c's frame of
reference so if you think about it from
c's frame of reference you could say
you could say that v
right over there let me just in a
different color
you could say
that v
is the velocity that a is moving away
from c at
so
velocity
a
moving
from
c
and then you could say that
u
is the velocity that b is moving from c
remember we're deal we're dealing in c's
frame of reference
so velocity
velocity that b
moving
from
from c and actually let me make
everything uppercase this should be
uppercase a and this should be uppercase
c
and in that case what is delta x prime
over delta t prime
well that would be the velocity that b
is moving away from a in a's frame of
reference i know this can get a little
confusing but i really want you to pause
it watch it in slow mo really think
about what we're doing
this i'm kind of starting now i know i
started this video in a's frame of
reference and this is really the trick
of the problem is i'm now shifting over
to c's frame of reference i'm like okay
v is the velocity a is moving away from
c b is the velocity or u is the velocity
b is moving from c
and in that case we can view delta x
prime over delta t prime as the velocity
that b is moving away from a in a's
frame of reference
so b
moving
from
a
in a's frame of reference so
in
a's reference
and both of these are in in seize
reference and let me write that down
in
c's
reference
in
c's
in c's
nc's reference i really want you to
think about this this is a little
confusing but hopefully this helps you
appreciate how this is an addition of
velocity addition can be valuable well
now we can we can put it we can
substitute what we know
we know the velocity b is moving away
from a
it is 0.8 c
so we can write
we can write
0.8 c
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to u the velocity b
is moving from c and c's frame of
reference well we say that's just going
to be v that's going to be a positive e
so that right over there is going to be
a positive v
let me do that in
let me do that same color
it's going to be a positive e and then
from that
we are going to subtract the velocity a
is moving from c in c's frame of
reference so a is moving from c with the
velocity negative v
i know it's kind of sub it's confusing
to replace a v with a negative e but
this is the generalized formula while
this is the actual value that we're
using in this case
so minus negative e
all of that over
1 minus
all that over 1
minus
the velocity of u times the velocity of
v
well or that's just going to be
that's going to be v times negative v
or negative v squared so i'll just write
that as negative
v squared
over c squared
and just like that we have set it up so
we can solve for v and the key
realization is is that we we said okay
there must be some spaceship c that
defines a frame of reference where a and
b are moving away from it
with velocities of equal magnitude and
so we use that information to go into
seize frame of reference and use the
einstein velocity addition formula but
instead of instead of knowing what
instead of knowing what these are and
then solving for this we know what this
is and we're assuming that these two
have the same magnitude and we're able
to solve for v and so let's do that
right now in fact i will do that in the
next video so that we have enough time
and i encourage you to solve for v on
your own before you watch the next video